hello and welcome to the new world
review a source for everything anime and
manga so long as that anime and or manga
has the word hunter in its title
preferably
twice and more specifically welcome to
the encyclopedia where today it is time
to examine the sheer insanity that is
karapika so
welcome to karapika a man who has
dedicated his life to a singular purpose
of retrieving the dismembered scarlet
eyes of his deceased clan members
very serious incredibly driven and i
would argue one of the most intelligent
characters in hunter hunter
possibly even the most intelligent if
you remove marijuana from the equation
which if i have my maths correct hunter
hunter minus mirom divided by krapika
equals subscribed to the new world
review for regular hunt onto content
uploaded straight into your youtube feed
there it is it's mathematically proven
that you should click that red button
don't go ignoring facts now and let me
know if you're a new subscriber in the
comments and welcome to the association
but karapaka is quite a tough character
when it comes to the world of men
primarily because most characters tend
to develop a core competency in one or
two specific khatsu and then innovate
and reapply it as need be like hisoka
for example one of the most feared nin
users in the series and he really only
has two abilities to his name graphica
is very much the opposite he revels in
complexity and uses nine in a way that
very few people in this world could ever
hope to however when it comes to nen it
should be stated that krapika does not
possess the ridiculous natural talent of
say a gone or a killer nor does he have
the advantage of their natural
physicality like kilauea having been
trained as a hardcore assassin and gone
just starting the series with superhuman
abilities for
reasons comparatively krapika is less
talented and more frail however as it
turns out in the world of men those two
things are meaningless compared to
another factor that being drive
and desire gone and kilaueku to run
rings around karapika in terms of raw
talent however they don't even come
close to equalizing his laser-like focus
on the desire to avenge his people and
combined with his unparalleled
analytical mind krapika is undoubtedly a
far more proficient end user than either
gone
killer and this has been quite clearly
shown to us at every step of the way
as krapika had crafted not just one but
an entire series of nine abilities by
the events of york new city whereas gone
and killer were still very much testing
out the basics
and in addition to this krapika also had
access to the more advanced applications
like shu well before the others did but
the other absolutely key advantage that
krampika has in the nenworld before we
even get into his abilities
is a master level knowledge of nen
theory in a world that emphasizes how
unpredictable nang combat is graphica is
able to navigate any situations like
he's able to see through the matrix or
something and more so than any of his
actual abilities this is what makes
krapika a true force to be reckoned with
allowing him to perform feats like
completely clowning the entire phantom
troop during york new city or perhaps
even more impressively become an active
participant in the succession war
currently taking place on the blackwell
one and with all of that in mind let's
now identify kropika's affinity as a
conjurer a category that fits him pretty
perfectly allowing krapika to sculpt his
aura into physical objects
and conjuration unlike many other
affinities requires a certain level of
strategic ability to use properly
otherwise you just end up with
characters like kino
chitu however under control of the right
people conjuration is shockingly
powerful and
spoiler alert kraka is indeed the right
people that's not where his affinity
ends though because currently karapika
is the only known character in
the world who has access to a second
natural affinity being specialization
and the theory behind this is that when
krapika activates his scarlet eyes it
moves him one step to the left on the
nen ring and
look there's no scientific explanation
for why this is and if i had to guess
i'd say it's because when krapika
activates his scalloped eyes it's
generally under extremely serious and
driven conditions
thus very much prompting his men to
respond in kind because that's how nen
works emotions
always trump science whatever the case i
really want to emphasize that
specialization is the key to
quite literally everything in regards to
kraft because none abilities
if he was restricted to being a natural
conjurer then his path in the series
would look very different and
very underwhelming and to explain why
this is we first need to take a look at
his crowning hatsu known as emperor time
this is the first of two specialist
abilities that krapiko's crafted and by
far the most important
and very very basically what this allows
kropika to do is to use abilities
generated by each net affinity at 100
effectiveness it's an important word
effectiveness and i know that probably
doesn't make a lot of sense right now it
sounds very vague but stick with me
because to dive into this we need to
introduce the concept
of nen levels yay and levels are also
quite vague in nature but they are used
to indicate an individual's mastery of a
certain infinity as well as accurately
gauge what their levels for the other
affinities would be
so very basic example if krapika is a
level 10 conjurer
then that means his maximum mastery of
transmutation his neighboring affinity
would be level 8. meanwhile his maximum
mastery would say emission would be a
level 4
because that is directly opposite
conjuration on the n-ring it does get
more complicated though because levels
do not tell the full story behind nen
taking the system as we know it it would
imply that krapika would be roughly on
par with a natural level for emitter
however
the natural emitter will always be more
powerful in this situation and this is
because not only would a conjurer be
restricted to level 4 mastery
but every drop of aura put into an
emissive ability would only be 40
potent whereas say aura spent on a
conjuration ability would be 100
potent meaning that the sunk cost for
engaging in an emissive technique is 60
of the overall aura spent which is
generally why it's a terrible idea to
use the opposite affinity on the n-ring
but most importantly this means that a
level 4 natural emitter will be
producing an ability at 100
while scrapping using level 4 emission
as a conjurer will only be able to
produce an ability at forty percent and
in case you're not following one hundred
percent
is a much larger quantity than forty
percent and what emperor time does which
gets greatly
greatly confused by the fan base is it
makes up the gap at this stage here it
allows krapika to negate the aura
cost of engaging in other affinities
meaning that whilst it is active he
could now equally match the level 4
emitter or a level 6 enhancer or a level
8 transmuter or a level 6 manipulator i
guess
which is a much more underwhelming
ability than most people think however
what it does is it makes all nine
affinities very viable options whereas a
standard natural conjurer would almost
never see emission as viable due to the
extraordinarily high cost for the
minimal output so in effect
emperor time gives krapika a swiss army
knife of net
options to work with whilst it is active
like most things then related though
this potent power comes at a potent cost
and every second spent using emperor
time will reduce krapika's lifespan by
1 hour which can obviously be very very
bad perhaps even fatal because if he
uses emperor time for too long then this
strain causes krapika to black out that
limit is about three hours and at that
point in the manga krapika passed out
for a further nine hours whilst emperor
time was still active and as such this
accidental 12 hour period cost krapika
five years of his lifespan overall so
it's very high risk and quite
problematic because krabika's further
abilities are heavily reliant on emperor
times activation now krapika's other
hatsu have their roots in conjuration as
he elected to conjure a series of chains
five in total each one assigned to a
particular digit on his hand
the first of which is known as the
dowsing chain and it's a rather simple
ball and chain often used for combative
and defensive purposes however it can
also perform some other utility actions
and has been used in the past to
determine the location of missing
individuals and it can also act as a
liar detector and furthermore with
emperor time activated
it can even be used as a lie detector
through video footage
and look this is another one of those
things that definitely doesn't make too
much scientific sense if any but it's
based on the idea of dowsing divination
so krapika has pre-loaded this ability
with those ideas and i'd like to point
out at this stage that just dowsing
chain would be a crazy enough none
ability for any one character to have
but we still have five more to go
through with krapika and the next one is
going to be holy chain and this is a
combination of conjuration and
enhancement quite specifically we have
krapika using enhancement to heal his
injuries which he can do rather easily
with emperor time active
and for example in the series he was
seen healing a fractured arm within mere
seconds which is pretty wild but once
again
emperor time is the key to this without
it active kropik's capabilities would be
significantly lessened to the point of
potential uselessness actually unless he
was healing like a paper cut or
something but next up we have judgement
chain which presents kraka's most
complex hatsu being formed by
conjuration emission and manipulation
the latter two affinities being a very
weak area for a contra and as such this
ability can only be used with emperor
time active but it's pretty ridiculous
because basically karoppaka is able to
send a blade and chain into a victim's
body
wrapping it around their heart and then
graphica is able to issue the victim
with a command which if violated will
result in the instant death of said
victim
a good example of which would be when he
ordered uvagine to tell him where the
rest of the phantom troop were overkin
refused and then judgement chain
promptly killed him this isn't the only
way judgement chain can be applied
though because weirdly enough krapika
has also used this ability on himself
and why you ask
well it's to set a limitation on another
ability and that hatsu would be
chain jail a very simple pure
conjuration existence that is designed
to wrap a target in
unbreakable chains as well as enforce
the state of zetsu in all
users and when i say unbreakable chains
that's actually impossible to create but
krapika does get pretty damn close
and it's all because he performed the
aforementioned judgement chain ability
on himself to set a condition that if he
ever used chain jail against someone who
was not a member of the phantom troop
then judgment chain would kill him
instantly
and in this weird fancy and surprisingly
mathematical world of men this
restriction actually resulted in changeo
receiving a significant power boost and
it is confirmed to be capable of
restraining any member of the phantom
troop unfortunate enough to be ensnared
in it all i can really say though is
that karapika better be pretty
damn sure that his target is a member of
the troop otherwise using chain jail oh
that's not going to end well for him and
just to dispel a common misconception
chain jail is actually the only ability
that has this limitation put on it
there's a common thought throughout the
hunt onto fanbase that all of krapika's
abilities are only able to be used
against the phantom troop but that is so
far from true it's just change air that
gets affected by this
and every other ability we've examined
as well as every other ability we will
examine is fair game for anyone so let's
keep going now with steel chain
which is steel as in s-t-e-a-l like a
thief rather than the metal substance-y
thing
and this is yet another ability in the
series that takes the abilities of
others making krapika sort of a
mini crawler it essentially consists of
krapika inserting a syringe on the end
of a chain into a victim
and temporarily acquiring one of their
abilities which also has the
insane effect of draining the target of
aura leaving them in a state similar to
that of zetsu and this hatsu can be
somewhat confusing because the two best
known
ability thieves in the series being
crollo and lyol are both specialists and
krapika did not therapy did not have his
scarlet eyes active when using steel
chain
meaning that he can use this as a
natural conjurer although i will say
that the scarlet eyes appear to have
been invoked shortly after
the ability but not during and i'll also
say that there is precedent for basic
affinities being able to steal nen
abilities and shikaku comes to mind this
man is a natural manipulator and thus
unable to access specialization at all
and yet he was able to craft a hot suit
on his cold sept which theoretically
allowed him to take the ability of
someone else and contain it within like
this nen
cardi thing with that said i can't quite
explain the technicalities of how
krapika can perform steel chain and
what's even more wild is that krapika
does not
lose access to the stolen ability if the
original user dies
which is one of crowler's hugest
restrictions it's also unclear as to
whether or not krapika needs to fulfill
various conditions like crollo and leo
had to
everything in the manga just happened so
quickly but i can't imagine that kropika
can do this without a ton of conditions
to meet one of which may be the
following sub ability which is called
stealth dolphin very
adorable sounding and this ability does
require emperor time to be activated
because it is pure specialization and
what it does is allow cropica to analyze
and equip stolen abilities which is an
important distinction from just stealing
them i think the implication here is
that steel chain can take abilities
however croppica cannot use them without
invoking stealth dolphin and at this
point i should also say that this
ability the stolen ability is fueled by
the aura that was drained from the
target which is once again
pure insanity because even without the
ability stealing aspect the fact that
this hearts who can just drain a target
of their aura is a guaranteed win
condition against any nen user should it
connect that's not it though because
krapika can use stealth dolphin in
conjunction with steel chain to loan the
stolen ability to another person and
given that it runs off stolen aura that
person doesn't even have to be an end
user although as a side effect it will
force their aura nodes open and it will
turn them into one thus
initiating them to nine which is the uh
frowned upon method of awakening
thankfully there are a couple of
negatives with this combination one of
which is that the stolen ability can
only be used once whether that be by
karapika or someone else
after which point it gets returned very
similar to leo's rental part actually
and while the ability is a new stealth
dolphin will
enforce emperor time meaning that
krapika is unable to voluntarily
deactivate it which can be very
problematic when someone else has
control of the stolen ability
in fact that's how krapika ended up
passing out and losing five years of his
life so as crazy as all of this sounds i
suppose it did come at a pretty grand
cost
still if krapka was careful then steel
chain pretty much immediately becomes
one of the most overpowered abilities in
all of hunter hunter
even more so than judgement chain in my
opinion it's fairly maddening though
because any one of krapika's abilities
would be
incredible for any nin user to possess
let alone all
six core abilities most of which also
have sub-functions attached attached
them as well
the trade-off being of course that to
use any of them to their needed level it
generally requires a direct exchange of
life so you could consider crappiker's
net mastery as the opposite theory of
the more established users in the world
for example people like netro and zeno
got where they are today by investing
the time into their study and practice
with great patience
and only now in their old age can they
wield such extraordinary power meanwhile
krapika has gone down the opposite road
choosing to wield extraordinary power at
a young age
in exchange for i suppose never making
it to old age so he is a brightly
burning nen candle fueled by vengeance
and who knows how much of his life he's
already exchanged to get this far
grandpa may very well have lost entire
decades of his life at this point which
makes every
needed use of nen that much more
dangerous to invoke but that is the
price that krapika is willing to pay and
it has made him one of the most
formidable nine users
in the entire series but what do you
guys think please do leave your thoughts
in the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more hunt onto content then please
do go and check out some of my other
videos or even subscribe to the channel
for regular hunt under glory delivered
straight into your youtube feed but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time